it is with the greatest honor and
humility that I would like to introduce
you all to his Excellency president Tong
he needs no introduction to many of you
indeed as I've uncovered walking around
New Haven with him for a day and a half
but he doesn't need to go far to be
recognized by people randomly and even I
have them asked to take a selfie with
him as you know he is the former
president of Kara months but truly he's
become known for his being at the
forefront of raising global awareness
about the existential threats caused by
climate change he's been described as
the world's climate warrior although I
can say I find him to be a little more
of a Zen warrior he's of course won many
awards and in recognition for his
climate work including the Hillary
laureate the Peter Benchley ocean award
for his work in creating the largest
maritime a protected zone of the Phoenix
islands which has since been recognized
as a UN World Heritage Site he's won a
ten Prize he's won numerous honorary
degrees and of course that Nobel Peace
Prize nomination but these are facts
that you might know about him I wanted
to share that the most important thing
that I've learned about him in the past
day is that I think at heart he is an
educator prior to entering political
life he was Chancellor a University of
South Pacific and I have never seen him
so animated as when he is talking to
students and answering questions and and
we've talked a lot about his vision for
the future and at the core of it is
education education for people from his
homeland to prepare them for the future
education of us and I look forward to
being educated more today so our plan
for this session is that I would like to
just show a clip of a trailer about some
of the work that's done this movie is on
the film circuit now and you can find it
and watch the length in the film in full
and then we're going to do a sort of a
Q&A session that Miraj Desai will sort
of do wheelchair Murata is also a fellow
member in the Department of Psychiatry
and the School of Public Health he's
remembered the Faculty of a climate
change initiative and although he will
be too modest to say this I will point
out that he's just published a book
traveling movement in clinical
psychology he and I are often asked how
it's like um psychiatrists and
psychologists are working on issues in
this area and that's again as I said the
beginning because there is life outside
the clinic and out life outside our
office and we would like to engage in it
in the fullest so thank you mirage for
helping with the questions and let me
just begin by showing this cannabis is
in the center of the world so it's right
there banging in the Pacific Ocean so
far away so isolated record it with
enuine from the tribulation something
the issue of climate change remains the
most pressing challenge for us
incubus why the sea levels have already
taken a village on one of your islands
do you see the possibility of all the
people from cure baths one day having to
leave
[Music]
for those of us on the front line it
really does not matter what is agreed to
in Paris because we will continue to go
into one
[Music]
if it is a foregone conclusion no matter
water what's the point
[Music]
we need to supply
what he's trying to happen to us is
going to be perfect
of the rest move
[Music]
[Applause]
present on
okay thank you mother for that
introduction in Europe especially before
we interact with with each other we
bless each other so let me do that this
morning but before doing so I want to
acknowledge the presence of the people
of this land and the elders and to
invite them to to join us in this
discussion as we engage as we try to
address one of the biggest challenges
ever facing humanity so let me bless you
but I also ask you to bless me back and
so what I would say is come to know the
meaning may you be blessed and you would
reply if I say no okay so let me bless
you come to Mary thank you if you didn't
bless me back then all my blessing would
come back to me okay they let me take
the opportunity to acknowledge the with
deep gratitude those who have organized
this and made me travel all the way from
that center of the world to the other
side of the world but it's something
that I'm always very happy to do because
let's say crusade which I'd been on
quite some time taken a lot of my time a
lot of my energy and maybe a lot of my
soul as well but I assure you it's well
worth it because we could never
understand underestimate what is in
stick I think what often we get we get
some very interesting observations by
very interesting people who tend to
underplay the gravity of what it is that
is coming and I think much of this is
quite often people who just refuse to
acknowledge and I can I can sympathize
with that because at one time I was in
denial because I couldn't face the
reality of what was coming I can assure
you there was a time when I I come to
the conclusion that we are in serious
trouble but I kept denying it there must
be it cannot be true but then there has
to be a time when you have to come to
terms with the reality
and you gotta begin to find your way out
of that depression I can tell you that
for a time when I started talking about
this at the United Nations General
Assembly nobody never been discussed at
that level but when I spoke nobody
listened to me because the focus one was
on terrorism it was about that time in
the mid 2000 2004 and so I got together
with my appeal I said how can we get
these people to understand that this is
worse than terrorism because it's going
to be such a massive proportions and so
we thought that what about one of my
staff said what about eco-terrorism okay
so let's incorporate that so climate
change is like it's eco-terrorism didn't
make a change
nobody was impressed but I kept at it
and then once I saw this article in the
National Geographic about the polar
bears I don't know some of you might
remember that there was this focus about
how or the poem from the Bears would be
losing their habitat but due to the
melting of the ice in the Attic
and I saw it I feel sorry about the
polar bear but I was looking for some
reference to us because we would be
equally threatened yes yeah there was
never any mention of people so I made
this comment and United Nations and I
think it's so bad people up to it you
want to realize that they were worried
about all of this is purpo not people
would be suffering an equal thing but
we're talking about a huge huge number
of people and so for quite some time
really nobody listened and then of
course we came to the 2009 Copenhagen
before that there was a meeting in New
York at the UN just around the U and
imagine some leeway meeting and there
was about two dozen leaders I was there
the only one from from I think the only
one
developing country as I recall but sadly
the only one from the Pacific and I
record the discussions and there was
they were all talking about the impact
of the what was being discussed as
possible remedies how damaging it would
be their economies and I was sitting
there filming so I scribbled a note so
the situation can I have a word I'd like
to help them and I said I'm hearing you
and I understand where you're coming
from but please also do understand where
I'm coming from I'm not talking about my
economy I'm talking about the survival
of that so give that a thought and I
remember President Obama had just come
into office that now always remember
what he said at that meeting said you
know I'd love to do something with the
United States on this but the u.s. is
such a huge beast you cannot general
around in one go I didn't fully
understand what he meant but later I had
pondered over it and I was expecting him
to deliver in Copenhagen he didn't and I
really was very disappointed but then I
reflected on that comment I understood
and I was waiting for a statement on his
reelection and he did make this
statement but I think the point that
comes out and all of this is we're
turning climate change into a political
football
it is not in our part of the world we
have wicked changes of government in
Australia New Zealand and with it I
change the policy on climate change
we had the Labour government in
Australia or we worked wonderfully and
then the other side came I would and one
of the prime ministers were saying
before he became prime minister you know
the kind of changes you know in his own
words crap
and he offended me and so I met him in
Bali I said you know when I used to be
in the opposition
I loved the luxury of being able to say
anything but once I came into office the
real world is a little different hoping
that he would change his policy he
did not so that's how we've been doing
this so I'll share with you some of the
real experiences I've had and the on one
occasion when we were building up to the
Paris agreement negotiations we in the
Pacific Lee Smolin Pacific Island
countries we're trying to consolidate
the opposition before that and we were
the minor 1.5 and then we went at the
Pacific Islands Forum meeting the
Pacific Islands Forum meeting in
includes all of most of the Pacific
Island countries plus Australian Musil
and of course when Australia New Zealand
came in they started watering this down
and we we did have a fight in the
retreat where nobody can see the fight
with the leaders because there's only in
the leaders okay
so there's a lot of untold stories there
but later on during the press conference
there was these two leaders and I was on
the other side I was the only one from
Alan come see me and they were talking
to a whole mess of media people I was
watching them and they really had no no
problem saying that you know two degrees
anything below two degrees and rising
global temperature is too much for us we
once that happens our economist masa and
we would not be able to achieve the
growth levels we need and I kept
watching myself of course the media
focuses on these people they are more
important so I said can I have a word
and of course they yes I'm I'm hearing
these two I hear them I understand where
they're coming from but two degrees even
1.5 even zero according to the report
suggests that we will our future is in
serious jeopardy so we're talking about
our future generation and these two are
talking about their economies make the
comparison and of course the media got
very excited when there's a fight on
between leaders the media love it all
the hands went up
but it was all orchestrated the one who
was conducting that's it no no question
is that but I think that is what's up
and then I I've said it said I don't you
can go to degree she can go 10 degrees
but as long as you can keep your
emissions within your national borders
do that and I assure you you can go
ahead and so this is the moral because
I've always regarded climate change and
that's the greatest moral challenge
facing humanity because why because when
you are here sitting in the United
States and if doing something or getting
something or forgoing something means
that you give somebody else a better
chance at the other side of the world
the question will be the challenge would
be will you do it or will you not do it
and I asked that question and of course
we have leaders who say no it doesn't
it's not relevant to us and we're
getting that message right now coming
here from your leaders in Australia from
their leaders and I've got the list here
Germany is about to start
coal mining again no ways about go
drilling into Nazi Canada is now
scooping up 10 cents the United Kingdom
is going to restart of frackin Australia
started mining opening the biggest coal
mine in the world and so in born when
you hear these people saying will will
cut our emissions and if they're if it
is true that Australia is cutting its
missions but exporting huge amounts of
coal and we stupid not to know that they
are actually lying to us what is the
heart of the issue the head of the issue
is to reduce emissions not to look good
but we have to be stupid not to know
that if the export call somebody else
they're giving somebody else to
opportunity to do what to increase their
emissions
I am I hope that an Australian say ha I
go to Australia tomorrow with a note or
to talk and I'll be there be shooting at
me I don't have a problem with that
because I think the truth has gotta be
told you know you gotta face these
people and they're because the less you
face them the border they become and I
think we've learned our lesson and our
lesson has been that we've been sitting
on the sidelines while all of this was
ongoing thinking that it's relevant to
us that we have no partner because we
ask more we aren't as culture but the
reality is this our future is at stake
and that is not inconsequential so I've
been asked what made you start talking
about this that very reason because we
always thought of ourselves as not
having much of a part in the
international discussions and I think
there has been our biggest biggest
mistake so I started going crazy and I
started talking at the United Nations
very radically angry at first read my
earlier statements and you knew since
then and frustration later I began to
understand that nobody listens to a
crazy radical one who points fingers
nobody likes to be printed at so don't
point at them blame somebody else but
you had talked directing your comments
but I learn to repackage this and I
found that it was actually more
effective people would then come around
and join you an opportunity to join you
or whatever and so I remained a radical
and so people ask me so what what how
how would you describe your campaign
well I'm I'm something like a rational
radical okay whatever that is your your
smart intellectual
you define a rational radical but I
think that's the way it's gotta be you
gotta be from their part of the world in
order to behead to be admitted okay and
so that's the way I've been conducting
my campaign speeding Ford with
disappointment but I can tell you
there's been quite a significant change
in momentum I remember being in Brazil
real for the 2012 conference and I
remember the some of the leaders were
talking and my staff came running and
they say hey he's repeating your
statements and I said good it means
they've been reading it now they want to
take it over that's exactly what I want
but I think this being this buildup of
momentum now everybody wants to do
climate change and even in my part of
the world this has been the case because
at the time that I was talking nobody
else considered it relevant now I'm so
happy as I've retired them my colleagues
have taken up the ball and started
running with it except from my own
government
well that film at the elevator says all
of what I've been doing is now being
unravel by the prison government but
that again is the example of
politicization of climate change
extremely stupid because we have no room
to play politics on this issue I don't
know why but they are beginning to that
when I understand a senior government of
course they were in the opposition when
I was in government maybe it's payback
to me but it's not taking us anywhere
it's undermining the momentum of the
campaign and apart it's watching what's
important is this nature does not care
what do you think it's not care what
government is in place there is a point
at which she was to say
he didn't take the warning something
sending you too bad your time years old
and so it's important to understand that
we may be on the front line and when we
started putting how the front line I
will explain to you because I do a lot
of fishing and I go I mean the boat and
I see these coconut trees falling as the
the land gets eroded so that those are
the trees on the front line but I tell
you the ocean will carry on
and those that we're not on the front
line will become the front line and they
will fall next exactly what is happened
I think what just happened the last
couple of days signals I I was on
interviewed from Radio Australia and I
commented on the comments of the
government Australian government in
response to the current IPCC report with
which they tried to under plays it's
irrelevant and my comment is says you
know we cannot keep closing our ears to
the fence
it doesn't change and so I'm already
being attacked on this but I think the
point that is so important is even
though we're a few several thousand
miles away from Australia we do not vote
in Australia and therefore are
irrelevant that the political leaders
force trivia whatever what happens next
is nice I guarantee you this coming
summer Australia's got a huge bushfires
where our people are gonna lose their
homes maybe their lives as well there
are farmers who is gonna lose their
farms cost up to long yeah
now that is relevant
those of you in Australia who do not
believe climate change is relevant will
in some way the effect that nothing that
is the truth um there's no doubt you
know this I mean in our part of the
world we thought we did not have
cyclones because we create cyclones and
we send them down to our friends in Fiji
when what - you know there are presents
because we're on the equator okay
and so the storms go but in 2014 one of
the storms came back up north again
flooded all of the trouble of islands
flooded all of the others and did the
same to our southern islands the rest of
the islands were flooded but to a lesser
extent but it damaged a lot of our food
crops I stopped it to matter who's been
to my home Island I said did you visit
that village because all of the
breadfruit trees at that now we derived
that is one of the most important source
of food for our people and some of the
one village is gone it used to be there
when I was young at the villages the
what's happened is the sea water has
gone in contaminated the first water
point killed all of the crops the taro
and the surrounding trees including
breadfruit corner and beginning income
people to contaminate the freshwater
lives very soon that community not in a
decade but well within the decade they
will have to relocate and there are
several other communities in the same
situation okay and so these are the
things that we are facing today
so because bit of geography let me know
if I talk too much because there you
know kill myself you said scene from the
film it's the very low-lying islands our
mountains are about three meters okay
about sea level and we don't have we
don't have rivers the islands are very
narrow strips of land and so what if
there is a high high tide and we are
getting these now
there's always overtopping another way
the words the the waves are coming off
and contaminating the water lines we
wait for a while and then it would rain
water would flush it out again but
that's what we have to do okay so what
happened
I was trying how what to do our people
think okay I mastered a lot I said no I
try not to to let them think because if
they think about it if they understand
it acknowledges and think about it their
lives would be so miserable as mine has
always been so my strategy has been not
to pretty relative to their thinking
that there's serious trouble ahead
because there is nothing they can do
about it and there is no point in trying
to make their lives even more miserable
but I think the burden is on the
leadership to try and do something about
it and so what did I do
I'll tell you what I did at the first
ask my if anybody if any of the people
that asked me what are you planning to
do because this is coming and my the
honest answer would have been to say I
really don't know and it's beyond how
control there's nothing we can do about
it and I have a nice over this and I
said you know this is not good enough if
that's the way if that's going to be my
answer I don't deserve to be sitting in
this seat I should go and so I seriously
I didn't rest and didn't sleep from
quite on them so I had go crazy fine
come up with crazy ideas and so I
started talking about I started talking
to the Japanese and the Japanese came up
with a floating island concept yeah you
will see them that room but they came up
I was in Tokyo and they invited me come
on this is we've been listening to you
and this is what we think might be one
of the universities was in partner with
that the the biggest construction
company in Japan
Shimizu and they came up with this
wonderful model I think it was about two
billion dollars with well if we had to
we'll find the two billion dollars but
at the moment we don't have it but those
are the kind of things that we have to
think about and then I thought about
raising the islands it seemed easier and
against all of this frustration sense of
futility depression as well I started
trying to put people around so I in God
our neighbors from the region the we who
are in similar situations to bond
Marshall Islands and the more leaves and
I called I I called the conference
climate-induced migration it's
interesting because he's precisely what
you're doing it and so to talk about you
know what our options and I put together
a coalition of at all nations on climate
change and the reason I did this was
because we're in deep trouble well ahead
of anybody else and there is no way I
believed I didn't believe that the
international community could will
deliver evident in Paris and Paris just
still does not deliver I remember when
our my people were going in for the
negotiations I said make sure there is a
strong provision for adaptation because
that is what we will need mitigation is
what we are well beyond mitigating it's
about trying to survive and it's about
adaptation what can the international
community come up with and of course
they came away empty-handed just a set
of words and we are still empty-handed
because what I remember somebody is
asking me one of the chairman of the UNF
Jeb Bush they said what do you like -
what would your people like to go back
único backward I tell you mr. president
they don't care whether it's 1.5 or two
degrees whether it's 450 or 350 parts
per million they did their work their
only need is some reassurance that they
will survive this so far
until today there's been nothing and so
what I did was literally give up because
the international community is not ready
to face this and so we had to go on our
own so I started talking to the as I
said the Japanese that I spoke to the
United Arab Emirates because they built
those islands and they started we
started engaging unfortunately I left
office by the time they finish the
report I haven't seen the report and the
government won't let me see it but it
does a very comprehensive evaluation of
how we might raise the islands it's part
of the the coalition initiative so that
if it's done in kill possess a pilot
project then the other countries if it
works they can replicate it so that is
still under consideration and yesterday
I had the opportunity to interact with
some people faculties and the students
trying to provoke their thinking trying
to challenge them and equally so I'm
asking you if you have any ideas how we
might survive this please don't be shy
and so our response which I said drafted
was that it would be a multi prong
strategy and it'll be based on the idea
an acknowledgement that we could not
even if we try to raise the evidence we
could not ever mobilize the resources to
raise all of the islands nobody's going
to do that so we have to contend
ourselves about the possibility that
maybe one or two islands in order that
how people would survive okay the rest
would simply have to go down so what
happens what happens there it's going to
be a totally different way of life but
what are the options I also accepted the
reality that some of our people not all
of our people can be accommodated and so
we had to accept the reality that some
may want to migrate and it's we
shouldn't provide them with the
opportunity to do that not only provide
them but actually empower them and
thence I came up with the idea I
I heard this eloquent lady talking about
climate refugees well not every time I
hear that I cringe because I hate the
terminology alright and the climate the
migration with dignity is precisely a
rejection of the notion of climate
refugees because being displaced is
hardly a dignified endeavor and I tried
to put some dignity into it and so it it
was so boosting from my own thinking so
I needed that and so I started talking
about migration with dignity and I
believed it I believe it because I think
what's been happening is we've denied
the reality that migration is part of
our adaptation adaptation beyond the
borders because we ran out of space
that's high above the water so where do
we go okay we have to adapt beyond our
borders
so having destroyed our home will come
and take over your home okay I thought
about I've been discussing with my
colleagues come on let's go you know
these people they discovered our stream
now let us go and read this commerce
field and take it over again okay but I
think that's the way it's going to be we
have to relocate but if there is to be
any relocation it is the obligation of
the leaders to prepare these people for
relocation and I I think what happened
in Europe was a mass migration from
North Africa is the prime example of our
migration was done without proper plan
and the reason is because we denied that
it was happening we denied that it was
going to happen and therefore it did not
prepare for it we hit our heads but we
know climate change is happening we
should train our people
so that if and when they migrate they go
as killed people who have a place okay
the first thing you when you leave your
home is to look for a place because in
your home
I don't you have a place but when you go
to a place like New Zealand you find a
place you kind of find yourself a place
and the place is here and it's here
mentally you've gotta find that place
the only way you can do that is have a
sense of confidence to move in and be
somebody not a burden to the society
that you go into but be part of the
leading the leadership to be able to
contribute to add value to where you're
going close the gap between that might
create misunderstanding because you
people would be coming from different
backgrounds and the less
misunderstanding the greater the
possibility of living in Hamel a highly
spoke with some people from Germany
hours and the cruise and full of elderly
German people I admire the Germans for
what they're doing but even they are
getting fed up we're hearing what's
happening is with you because and that
is natural because there is not that
preparation there is not that program
for ensuring that the differences are
minimized so that not only people have
less friction but they can enjoy each
other's company okay here in the United
States
you're the biggest nation of migrants
you have your tensions but yet you are
the most successful nation on this
planet maybe not for long I don't know
[Laughter]
but I think and that is the notion of
migration with dignity and I am serious
I meet our people and different
communities in different I said come on
go go to school educate yourself become
good become my sport as your people
become leaders in your community and I
look forward to some of you being going
going into Parliament I look forward to
the day when one of you will become
Prime Minister in this country but don't
quote me I'm not trying to be president
in this country yeah I might be fun I
think but I think that's what climate
change means it's a serious serious
challenge and unfortunately we're not
taking it but we're not giving it the
proper focus of attention I I have not
gone into all of the detail because I
believe we have questions and I think
I've gone over twenty minutes and but I
think we've got a question and answer so
I'll let you have that opportunity to
maybe pursue some of the issues that
that you want to follow and please don't
worry about asking difficult questions I
love difficult questions because in
Parliament they always ask the most
difficult questions it's deliberate and
they do it because they already know the
answer sorry but you get a I'm gonna ask
me a difficult question I know how to
answer it I just talk about something
else
[Applause]
hello so thank you president Tong I've
had the pleasure and honor of getting to
know president Tong over the last three
days and I found him to be a person of
extraordinary grace courage and humility
which is rare and our leaders these days
and it's really you cannot help but be a
walk away affected by his presence also
what I've noticed is your strong moral
vision and then you articulated a bit
yesterday and so the first question is
what informs this moral vision of yours
what influences it you know I I'm trying
to live by what I demand of people and I
say that if ever you have the capacity
to do anything about anything then you
have the obligation because I believe
God gave us different talents you know
one of us might some of us asthma you
know one or all good fisherman went out
but the fear of wood fishermen you're
obligated to share your cash when they
come back if you're a good what because
God gave me the talent but he also gave
me the responsibility to share and so I
think in doing this it's it was driven
as I said by the fact that we did
standing on the sidelines while our
future is being determined in the
boardrooms
here in New York maybe somewhere else in
Tokyo and that's not acceptable I mean I
I was brought up in a colonial era and I
don't want a repetition of that we want
to be able to check charge of our future
so you mentioned the colonial era and
you spoke on this briefly yesterday but
what do you see as the relationship
between climate change and the legacy of
colonialism and countries who were
formerly colonized well I think we
thought we were decolonized in 1979 but
I assure you the process continues the
process continues and I had you during
my time in office until today I
continued you are here why why we cannot
kill the process one of the largest fish
resources in the world most it's most
likely that the toner you eat comes from
out of the world because interest in the
Central and worsen pacific we host 60%
of the healthy remaining stocks of tuna
and so yet and it's billions it's worth
billions and billions of dollars but
we're not getting the millions we only
get less than 10% of the value on the
side of the wolf not when it gets into
the rich ocean and so that is that
continues to be the form of colonization
we remained the source of mid-tier the
source of raw material and we're not
getting equity analysis and so but
climate change we are suffering and we
will be the first ones to go sometimes
when I in moments of deep despair I said
okay we're just collateral damage and
once it happens maybe the rest of the
world will wake up and say oh it's true
they're gone and I'm sure that those for
those who have taken the trouble to
think deeply into this project they're
thinking into 50 years and from here
they will think likewise because that is
the future we're heading into unless
radical measures are checked by put into
place
to address this
and on that issue of radical measures um
this question is how do we address the
disparity between wealthy countries hi
adaptive capacity to vulnerable
countries need for such capacity okay I
think I've touched on that because we it
depends what you're I mean you hit that
highest mountain is 3 meters so we're
more vulnerable than anybody else and
with the change in climate and I see the
most immediate dangers not the rise in
sea level but the change in the weather
path once we begin to get the storms our
islands are going to go during the storm
that I spoke about some islets in Tuvalu
and we're not a no longer me they just
got washed out ok so the question is
what is to be offered what are we going
to do this is the question that I so I
guess then do you feel our current
global governance regime is aptly
structured to handle some of these
global challenges we must not make the
mistake of believing that national
leaders will address global challenges
they don't they think about the next
election now your leaders will think
about the next election not the next
generation because that's thinking
globally and climate change is a global
phenomena but we got national leaders
going in to negotiate and this is it
negotiate and if we're not negotiating
against each other we're trying to find
that find the red line beyond which
nature would not allow us to go and I
think we miss that we think we are
negotiating trade and access and
what-have-you that is not the case and I
think that is the biggest
we make I've always argued that we need
global leadership
we don't need Prime Minister's we need
global leaders to tackle climate change
so the theme of the global now we'll
switch a bit to the local how has the
culture of care bas informed your work
and advocacy and activism well we
believe in how culture of sharing I mean
it's very rare I don't think anybody in
Krita personally was alone you know I've
got about two dozen people in my home
that's the way it is and I remember I
gave a talk I think in Portland wasn't I
said you know any of us we do this you
know I'm with me here in United States
I've seen the movies that this I see
this beautiful huge apartment and then
one single person comes on nobody else
in the house but maybe a cat okay yeah
so we need more of them okay sharing
okay and is there anything that gives
you hope right now what gives me hope is
the fact that the not to AB hope is
unacceptable the give up is not
acceptable and so we have to keep
looking and looking for some goodness in
the hearts of those that have the
capacity to influence them I know that
sometimes you I listen to people and
some people very really frustrated me
and I cannot understand and I sometimes
I say if you go to Mass don't bother
don't bother going to church because
there is no Christianity in you doing
things that you know with the knowledge
that the information that we have today
if you know what that what you're doing
is damaging and killing people at that
side of the world why do you continue to
do it and at the same time go to church
they are contradictions
so interesting you mentioned that
religion and spirituality that's
actually the next question yesterday you
had some beautiful descriptions of the
spirituality of care bus and how that
relates to this issue so what would you
say is the role overall role of religion
or spirituality in in relation to the
issue of climate and I think it has to
do whether what I could always say that
climate change is the greatest moral
challenge facing humanity and why
because it's a test of our values as
human beings you know do we value the
next human being other than ourselves so
I said all about me first and I think
we've got to get away from me first
let's talk about us instead of me and I
think this is what I think we we can we
can share with the global community that
it's in communication is never about you
it's about us and it can be frustrating
sometimes especially if you're the one
carrying most of the load and it's uh
it's it's as I say but spirituality is
about the connection with the world
things okay there's a great deal more to
this world than what Tesla okay then
what there's a big world out there when
I in acknowledging the presence of those
we cannot see because there is that well
and we've got to learn to connect with
them to understand that there is much
more beyond the material okay and
sometimes you've got to think about the
larger picture I mean nature itself is a
world on its own
because we make the mistake
of saying that nature is there to
provide for us
don't take God's will literally when you
said yeah you had the Lord of all things
but what he didn't explain was that we
are part of that nature we kill nature
and we kill ourselves so we've got to
learn to respect and I know I understand
that there is there are these
conferences I go to when they talk about
indigenous people and so there are
indigenous people and some of them may
be we are interesting as some of you are
not indigenous but if you're not
indigenous
it must be aliens because everybody is
integers all we need to do is reconnect
back to our Byng indigenous relating to
nature relating to each other and I
think this is something that perhaps we
in a part of the world can teach the
rest of the world so we have questions
coming up but in the meantime what would
be your ideal solution then I mean this
is a broad question of course but you
can be as radical and creative as you've
been speaking about the last few days so
okay let me give you an example when I
was screaming to the world that the only
way to deal with climate change is to
make sacrifices okay and be very
committed so when I was saying this
that's when I closed off the what was
then the largest marine protected area
in the Phoenix islands particularly it's
more than 400,000 square kilometers of
ocean it's the prime fishing ground bow
fishing partners were very very angry
but it said this is our gift human
humanity the challenge was that what is
your gift
okay but I think the point is that we
can all make a contribution and
everything we do and I think the latest
report is really painting a very very
dire scenario
yeah the world the planet is in serious
trouble
and so it's going to be too late to try
to respond if we don't respond begin to
respond today we have to learn to give
up a number of things okay maybe just do
things differently and I know I'm going
as I said I'm going to Australia and
I'll be attacking the occult policy
because they I don't like okay because
the IPCC is really clear
coal is the most polluting source of
fuel and yet why you're sure that
government is doing this because it
believes it would lower the price of
energy but they've not taken into
consideration the other costs my
information I don't know maybe some of
you know there is that renewable energy
is now a lot cheaper than fossil fuel as
a source of energy so what makes us what
continues to lead us towards that path
of destruction why do we continue to do
that when we know that we can take this
alternative path so you tell part of you
the way you speak is you tell very
effective and poignant stories as well
and the way the way you way you speak so
this question is what stories have been
most effective in persuading sceptical
audiences around the world I used to
talk about family change I throw in
functions and then the church leaders
will come and say virtually not looking
at me by saying you know what is being
saying is rubbish
God created this world and God is the
only one that can destroy nobody else
and so I shaved my head in frustration
and so that's why I won't see the Pope
2014 I go I need to go and see the Pope
because I need somebody on my side of
course the Pope after that we had a very
long discussion he came out with the
the cyclical really reaffirming that
what the parts that we discussed and so
I came back smiling because their boss
is telling them that I was right but the
story that I tell and I've told this
several places I don't know where the
origin of the story came from but it is
very very effective and it's very
relevant and this is it relates to your
Hurricane Katrina where this was there
was this lady who was highly religious
and the children let's let's go the
floods are coming he said no I'm all
right
my mother God would would look after and
so she stayed they all were
they sent a boat back to a collector and
she said no I'm all right
the next time they send a helicopter
because she was on top of the roof she
still said no I'm all right and of
course she died and when she was going
to heaven she come marching in the gate
and said where is this God I said him
over there having some some champagne
and martyrs up to God and say a day
where were you I was looking for you why
didn't you deliver me oh but lady I did
three times where they turned me away
three times okay and this is very
relevant in terms of the way we believe
in God because we want to blame God for
everything even delivering this but I
think that story is very relevant and I
think I hope that it changed the views
of our church ladies in my country so it
seems part of that is getting within
understanding their own frames of
explaining this but also challenging it
then the inside almost I'll tell you
another story okay
here it's relevant to you people in
United States okay Steve there's two
these two neighbors okay they live next
door to each other and this this guy is
got a tree which is mixed turning around
when it's driving difficult so I cut the
tree and the tree fell on his neighbor's
house destroyed it totally so you'll
never do his neighbors
all for you your house is is destroyed
what are you gonna do about it
okay that is what's happening in towards
the end United States you know what your
answer will be Oh take it to court can
we take you to court no and that is what
we are facing we cannot remedy we cannot
seek justice for the injustice
so you mentioned some relations to the
USA so how can your experience inform
some of the smaller displaced
communities in the USA for instance or
this was a question what's the so that
where there are displaced communities
within the USA here as well so how can
your experience may be in form like
countries like this that are
experiencing internal types of
displacement well we're beginning to
have that we already have religious we
have gone I I keep this a village in the
place where I used to go to Scotland and
the village is gone but that the one
church building remains because they're
gonna dismantle it and it was being
eroded but I asked the religious to
build a seawall around it so whenever
the tide is in there's this single
church building sitting out in the
middle of the sea and so I this is what
I showed the people okay and so how do
you deal with it I think we've got to be
responsible we got to be moral I know I
caught often make reference to the
Titanic
you know what the Titanic sank and there
was just a few lifeboats but too many
people so those that were in the water
if they came up scrambling to try and
set themselves but you push them away
with you
hold on on board and that is the
question that those of you we have the
capacity to do something about somebody
else's problem
what after face that is the more of a
challenge and any there are displaced
communities they will be looking for
assistance
do we have tomorrow capacity just step
forward so we have maybe five or so more
questions possible five minutes okay so
five minutes five minutes which is so we
have a few questions that have been
asking about your thoughts on the
current negotiations and discussions
with Fiji regarding cross-border planned
relocations or really the plans with
Fiji oh yeah oh I tell you what I put
Fiji in a difficult situation because I
went ahead and bought land in Fiji and I
was criticized heavily criticized for it
but it's part of the it's part of the
strategy to tell the world that it is
serious that we're not waiting for you
we're gonna go ahead and make plans but
wonder what I didn't do was tell the
Fijians I bought land and so when the
media people started asking me did you
buy land to move your people I began to
get worried because the Fijians know we
we're not invading Fiji they're
cannibals that probably got people who
offended but that was the implication
and it was actually debated in
Parliament but the creditors Fijians
they the only question raised was the
land was the land that was purchased by
the current US government was it native
land or what and it was freehold so
there was no further question but I
think there is that underlying question
now people coming in but then to the
credit of the Fiji government later they
came forward and stepfather said Fiji
will welcome the people from CalPERS and
Tuvalu if ever they need a place to go
due to the rising seas and so that's
been the first ever positive response or
to all of the multiple
challenges that I put forward through
the international community and so I
took the trouble to say it in Paris too
to ensure that Oh shame to all of you
because you're not stepping forward and
I think that is the kind of response
we're looking forward New Zealand I
think it's beginning to what take 10 to
10 to the 4 steps for what I I will
I intend to visit New Zealand to try and
take a full step forward to come forward
but they already do that what they do is
they allocate a place of 75 per annum so
these are the people who would otherwise
not qualify for through the normal
channels and so they are kicked at
random but what we find is how people
will go there what number of them come
back because they're not equipped to
handle the needs for getting a job
living in and so this is why I talk
about preparing people because it's got
to be a more structured program so it is
possible but it's not it's actually more
than possible it's inevitable it's
inevitable given what's happening those
countries would I then let the boat sink
and I know they are [ __ ] position
and this is very very tough at the
moment but that's why I suggested will
go and rediscover Australia so I I'm
going to be selfish and I have a
particular fondness of islands my wife
Michelle being from Mauritius and her
family as we were describing and close
friends in Hawaii and can you you've
been speaking about over the last few
days your work with other islands and
how has that gone or you can give us a
quick take on what that's been like in
terms of the Solidarity from islands ok
yeah for some time we in the islands we
got it ourselves and there speaks more
in consequential not a part of the
discussion
with discussions but I think that was
understood and then we began we realized
that we're actually very huge ocean
states I mean we got 3.5 million square
kilometers of ocean and likewise the
other Pacific country so we started
referring to our services Oh large
oceans ocean states and we began to take
acid as a group we began to take a more
a more direct participation in
international affairs and I'm glad to
say that pushing climate change to the
top of the agenda I think the other
countries were partly responsible with
doing that
suddenly I kept bothering the the then
Secretary General but what happened also
was that as a as a block we put the
ocean in the human agenda under this
DG's okay 2030 it had not been done
before so it is important but let me
tell you a story about the Sikh religion
when I eventually I convinced him to
visit kilobase and he did in 2011 so I
said them to go and look around came
back in the even I said so what what's
your what did you find
now I understand what you be saying not
only do I understand I feel so I promise
you I'll do everything in my time and so
but what he never told anybody and I
keep I follow him and I said what is
this interview was all the while it was
nuclear missile all these security
people who are walking around with life
jacket for him just in case the waves
come over and the reason is because in
kilobits when you're standing you're
always standing at eye level with the
sea so when the wave starts coming in if
you're not used to it you think they're
gonna come over you and so that is the
extent of vulnerability but we're used
to it
and there's a couple questions related
hear about multilateralism so we're in
an era of a lot of criticisms of global
cooperation and do you see climate
change is potentially an issue that can
revitalize multilateral
I I think it's uh it seemed I've done
that in Paris but I think if you notice
the trend now it's a beginning to
unravel people are pulling back and I
did expect that because in Paris I think
the French presidency really pushed the
agenda in bang what the hammer before
anybody could object but I I know that
there were countries who come to raise
objections but they didn't have that the
opportunity so that is beginning to come
down and so the United States he's
talking about was drawing Brazil would
draw Australia saying that pretending to
be following the word but actually in
reality sending emissions to China to
burn coal and so and all of the other
countries that are doing this now that's
not leading us towards the path of of
saving this planet we pretend because we
look good in in Copenhagen I remember
the the statement by the Indian Minister
for environment I remember and I really
wanted to get to this guy because he was
and he when he went back he made the
statement and Taliban to say oh I'm so
happy that I said attach the way the
Copenhagen process
and then I met this guy last year and he
started talking and I didn't remember
him but he said oh I remember the
president was there oh so you were the
guy that I really want to get to but I
think having said that in Copenhagen
then I was in India to talk at the the
Delhi should would stop the paccheri
their former chair and I spoke there and
I said I'm gonna really hammer the
Indian government but what happened was
the Prime Minister was there to open and
it gave a totally different statement
said India would be a part of the
process
and to me in fact what it missed me up
because I couldn't read my speech
because it became irrelevant because of
what the Indian Prime Minister said but
but I think there was bad but the
question you gotta ask this is a sincere
desire to save the planet or is it to
maintain good
relations they said to serve other
purposes and it goes down to the fact
the point that I made earlier that quite
often we are thinking from the national
perspective none of us are seriously
wanting to save this planet because we
still don't believe that it is in town
so we have a few more questions up here
then we'll have one okay so one one here
and then okay so this is a very so
though I'll have to give the last
question up here to the student so we're
here at a university and I think a lot
of students are interested in career
paths that you might recommend to become
global leaders on this issue it's an
open field out there and I think it's a
it's an area that could never get enough
people to advocates and I actually what
I do is recruit recruit and so first of
you what do you recruited please come
along because I assure you what I've
been doing is at every opportunity speak
to people but quite often I'm speaking
to people really believe and I I do
welcome interacting with people who do
nothing some once in a while I I enjoy
interacting with people who do that but
there are people who really genuinely
want to know and there are those that
come from totally different what a
totally different agenda and it's it's
difficult to interact with those people
but I think each one of you is more than
welcome I plan to retire I've been
planning to retire since I retired and
the more of you will come on board the
light of the load I can do happen
because I believe that it's not the
leaders that we need to talk to its the
voters because we need voters to tell
their political leaders because now they
think it's politically expedient
to do away with climate change because
it doesn't deliver the immediate
benefits like reducing the costs of
energy but what we need is the young
people especially to say don't mess up
our ok if you do you will lose the next
election
this is powerful and I think we need as
many people to do that so each one of
you if you can then recruit a hundred
imagine imagine what we would do to this
world maybe we would have a hope in
saving it so thank you and we have one
more question
hi my question is sort of similar to the
one just asked but I was just really
struck by the first thing you said about
there being a moral obligation to share
the skills and the knowledge that you
have and you know me and all my friends
we have world-class education Zhai go to
Wesleyan University all these resources
and we all want to save the world and
our futures are just completely blank
slates and I guess my question is how do
how do we keep in our sights that that
the the wine to use our skills to save
the world without losing that in the
rush of of growing up and getting more
focused and and becoming like the world
leaders now or the older generation and
yeah how should we channel that into
something actually useful that will that
will help people let me share with you
because I was also a young lass I think
I still am person but you know we all go
through this and I assure you because I
went back to my old school a little time
a few years back and I was talking to to
the students I said that was there among
you at one time and I never imagined
that I'd be sitting I really imagined
that I believed in my country one day
but it's the path that is sometimes they
be predestined
and I think be open to do that
because I believe that once life is
meaningless until you can deliver
something to somebody else other than
yourself and see whether all the skills
the knowledge the intellect that you
possess if that is entirely just for
yourself what is the joy in that so life
used to be sure because the more you
share it the more you the greater of the
value of your life becomes and so I
think the simple secret is look beyond
yourself because everything else will
reflect that
[Applause]
[Music]